Ukraine and Russia are accusing each
other of blowing up a major Dam sparking
warnings of severe flooding in
russian-controlled territory Downstream
in the region of Curson wood levels have
risen by 10 meters in the area
people are being evacuated from
surrounding Villages Ukraine's military
blames Russia for the damage but Moscow
appointed officials say the dam was hit
by Ukrainian shelling
the Nova kakova Dam links the banks of
the danipro river held by Russia on the
south and Kiev on the North water from
the dam is used to cool the reactors of
the zaparita nuclear power plant further
up the denipro river
or get reaction from Moscow in just a
moment with journalist Julia chapovalova
but let's first speak to Sean Stratford
he's in Kiev for us and Charles what is
Ukraine first of all saying about this
attack on the dam
well Ukraine is laying the blame
squarely on the Russians for this what
they describe as an attack Ukrainian
Military Intelligence said that this was
an attack in their words because of
panic amongst the Russians in uh Panic
about a potential Advance by Ukrainian
forces we've had a lot of speculation
that uh that the ukrainians will indeed
try and take back control of areas south
of the danipro river there was evidence
of that only last month whether the
reports of Ukrainian forces having
crossed an area of the NEPA River closer
to Northern Crimea but the ukrainians
saying that they are around 80
settlements that are now having to be
evacuated we've seen pictures of water
flooding into areas in some of the
settlements uh certainly to the east of
Herson and so there are huge concerns
about flooding there are huge concerns
about electricity power outages as well
local authorities in Russia saying that
they expect that uh the the river could
rise up to 12 meters the ukrainians are
saying that they'll know exactly the
extent of the damage and the the height
of the water in around about four or
five hours from now and of course there
are huge concerns about this nuclear
plant Europe's nuclear plant that's it's
further up the river
um massive concerns that this could
affect the cooling systems of that plant
okay Charles many thanks indeed that's
the view there from Keith let's now
speak to Janice Juliet she's joining us
from Moscow what's the reaction we've
had Julia from the Russian authorities
in control of this region of Curson and
Moscow
well actually we haven't heard from
Russia's top ranking officials yet but
the local pro-russian authorities of
Norway
denied the accusations uh the Russia's
behind the destruction of the station
they have also said that the kahovska
hydroelectric power station cannot be
restored the russian-appointed mayor of
the town of Norway Vladimir leontev said
that the destruction of the station was
a catastrophe which was created by the
Ukrainian authorities and those who
controlled them as we heard from the
Ukrainian side the explosions at the
gehobska power station meant that the
Crimea would be left without water but
according to the head of Crimea xionab
there is no threat of flooding in Crimea
GT the destruction of the of the station
but there is a risk that the north
Crimean Canal will get shallow also as
we know Ukrainian the Ukrainian side
said that this situation also creates
risks for the zaparosian nuclear power
plant due to the possible shortage of
water to cool the reactions but
according to the iaea there is no
immediate threat to the zaparosian
nuclear plant as there is enough water
right now to cool it down basically the
kahovska station was built back in in
the 1990 in 1950s I should say and over
the past year the Armed Forces of
Ukraine according to Russia of course
have been regular shelling di kehovska
hydroelectric power station and in
October last year Russia created a
letter for the U.N security Council
calling on Kiev to prevent the
destruction of the dam in March this
year the head of the of Novak
actually said that the hydroelectric
station had received significant damage
over all those months and that it is
still impossible to carry out
restoration works but the station was
perhaps in the working condition okay
Julia many thanks for bringing us the
view there from Moscow Julio chapovalova
reporting from Moscow